the documents and I've seen there's two
versions of them I've seen both versions
and they're a daily briefing document or
allegedly a daily briefing document from
the 1st of March day 370 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day special military
operation today is day 408 so just over
a month old right so what have we
learned so you say there are two
documents here there are two versions of
it and what they are are updates on the
flow of Western Equipment into the
Ukrainian forces a restructuring the
Ukrainian forces an assessment of what's
going on on the ground an assessment of
the weather and the conditions for
potential counter-attacks and a number
of other things one of the areas that
there has clearly been changes in is an
assessment of the casualties and one
document assesses Russian casualties to
be at a certain level there's another
document that is has almost certainly
been doctored that has Russian
casualties done as low as
um 17 500 dead now to put that into
context UK defense intelligence a couple
of weeks ago assessed Russia dead as
between forty and sixty thousand
ukrainians themselves assess Russian
dead as over a hundred and seventy
thousand so far
um and the original document that's in
there had a figure that was closer to
what the UK was talking about but we
have to be wary of disinformation at the
moment you know going back to the second
world war disinformation operation
mincemeat their most secret documents
that were released by their allies in a
way that they knew that they would get
to Hitler's desk they did and that
convinced Hitler that the Allies were
going to attack in through the power not
through Normandy we've got the Ukrainian
spring contrafensive coming up and it
would be important to get documents out
there either from the ukrainians trying
to
suggest something different to the
Russians or from the Russians trying to
undermine what the ukrainians are doing
yeah can we have a look at the conflict
as things stand at the moment is that
going to have a lot of bearing on on
this spring offensive then it it it will
have a bit of a bearing on it there are
two things that are important to the the
Springer sense of one is the timing of
it and this document if accurate will
give the Russians a better understanding
as when the ukrainians of the right
number of troops in
um the right number of New pieces of
Western Equipment in when they'll be
properly trained in it and as I said
there's an assessment on the ground
because
um if the ground is hard enough for
armored maneuver that that is quite
important
um and what it doesn't do though is the
other bit which is say where the attacks
should go in and that is still the gift
of the ukrainians the ukrainians at the
moment are successfully fixing the
Russians and everyone's attention and
back mood yeah what's happening there
specific and back mode you know the the
Russians have made a little bit of
progress they've crossed to the western
side of the buckmut river
um and are putting more pressure on the
center of the town but the ukrainians
are still holding on WE predicted that
that would fall
um quite quite a while ago
um the the ukrainians could if they
believe that the Russians are weak
enough in their carry out one of their
first counter-attacks in through back
mode and Fracture that fracture that
attention that's there everything seems
to be focused on we've got a 1200
kilometer front line uh the other place
the ukrainians could attack into is the
salvatony criminal Gap that's their an
important line of communication take
another bite of territory back in the
same way that they did with heart cave
um earlier last year another area where
there's a lot of activity going on at
the moment is in advika
um uh just to the north of Donetsk and
the Russian regular military are
fighting in there but have had some
significant losses
um and if the ukrainians felt very brave
and I don't think this would be what
they'll do in their their first part of
the counter-offensive but if they wanted
to really fracture the Russian defenses
they could combine from the zaparisia
region down south to the coastline
around Mario Paul or Milito Paul in that
sort of area breaking that land bridge
between Crimea and the disputed donbass
which is all important to the Russians